bye
the cia's been on company business for
years so what's been its job in france
italy guatemala iran cuba and the congo
and what does colby know and aj jackson
braden nixon marchetti helms bundy
stockwell church and what about truman
ike kennedy the cia's been on company
business in stealth
now we find out
[Music]
this man produced the movie on company
business
the cias on company business all through
latin america
maybe in ecuador and maybe in argentina
and maybe in brazil
but what's the meanie connection and the
point of killing an american cop in
uruguay
who's behind political torture and the
bomb squads
the cia's on company business in the
sixties
this man also directed the documentary
on company business
the cia wielded its hand in chile in
1973
and later on even while the senate
struggled to figure out exactly what
that hand was doing the ever active c i
a was pushing a strong arm in angola and
then the cia's favorite success story
came to an end
the cia in the 70s on company
business uncompany business has won
awards and has been shown in over 35
countries around the world
alan frankovich its producer and
director is with us tonight to tell us
his story on alternative view
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening welcome to alternative
views our guest tonight is alan
frankovic who's the filmmaker who made
the award-winning documentary on company
business that's a three-hour documentary
giving a history of and exposing some of
the operations of the infamous cia to
begin would you like to give some
background about what led you to make
the film in the first place to take on
the cia
well this was a film which was five
years in production and i started
working on it in 1974 1975
and
it was apparent to me at that moment and
you have to remember that in 1975 the ci
was
under investigation on the verge of
being investigated that nobody
was going to
really
go into the cia and arrive at the
conclusions that i thought one had to
arrive at because of the collusion
between the cia and all
institutions of the american
establishment
but on the other hand there a lot of
people were starting to talk for the
first time about things which had been
done in secret over long periods of time
and i was able therefore to interview a
whole series of people
at every level of the ci from directors
down to secretaries and accountants
and then spent a great deal of time
actually researching
coverage
of events sometimes
this involves ci created propaganda
which they inserted into
the world media and other times it
involved
contrasting what we were being told was
happening in some country
and then contrasting that with the cia
operatives telling you what they were
really doing and that this was official
united states policy except it was
conducted secretly so that we
the citizens of this country would never
know about it
how did you decide that this was the
time to make
a film about the cia what do you what
did you think needed to be told to the
american people about the cia and what
was your goal in making that film
well really i think the main point
really is that this country's had a
secret foreign policy ever since the end
of the second world war
and one of the essential instruments has
been the central intelligence agency you
know those we've had presidents every
president since truman has made great
morale pronouncements
but the ci has been the instrument they
have used actually
too consistently and in every part of
the world this is interesting it's not
only in third world countries the first
ci operations were in europe
and
you have
the united states government
making great moral pronouncements and
statements
while it's using this instrument to
penetrate infiltrate and destroy
anything which they which gets in the
way of what they define
as the interest of the united states and
if you look at the historical record and
you look at the countries the film goes
into
you find
that for instance
the operations they conduct
they haven't bothered asking us if we
felt threatened by this that or the
other thing
and often their economic interests that
they're defending as a matter of fact i
would say almost always
and in some cases the same
entities that in this country
don't care
whether an american worker has a job or
not are
doing everything they can to destroy the
capability of anybody in these other
countries controlling their own destiny
i think your film documents very well
the infiltration and manipulation of
trade unions in the third world where
they support the right-wing trade
movements to try to
keep these countries from forming more
radical
trade union movements so you intended
just simply to tell the story of the cia
from the end of world war ii to the
present day to give a history of it and
tell the people the truth or what you
perceived as the truth about the cia
that the media had covered over
well the thing was really to to get
people in the ci who were talking for
the first time to sit them down have
them tell the audience what they did
and to show consistently over 30-year
period of time that there were certain
methods which were used and they had
nothing to do
with
national security essentially they had a
lot to do with
justifying these operations whether
they're against chile or guatemala or
angola or in european context they had a
lot to do
with
intervening in the internal affairs of a
whole series of countries to force them
to comply
with what presidents of the united
states want these countries to do
and
these kinds of activities are not
something which just happened in moments
of crisis they go on every day in every
country of the world
and they're
the official but secret foreign policy
of this country and they're done
specifically on presidential orders and
what will happen in 1974 1975 and i
believe
it happened primarily because one of the
political parties in the form of richard
nixon started using the same agency
inside this country
against not against dissidents might
because i think against a major
political party and therefore when that
starts happening you have to
tell your guys look this far no further
and you start investigating them you
have to make a real investigation
because they know all kinds of secrets
they know where all the berries the
bodies are buried and therefore
to bring them in you have to investigate
them but the conclusions i knew in 1974
75 they would never conclude that these
were official government operations that
american presidents had ordered them
because the very nature of the ci
is to conduct these operations in secret
in such a way that if the united if the
ci is caught
they take the responsibility themselves
and the president of the united states
is protected
is that why they said that the cia was a
rogue elephant exactly that was the
conclusion and if you look for instance
if you look at the ci the assassinations
the ci
uh claims they planned but never
executed
you will find in several cases the
church committee went into the lumumba
assassination the assassination of the
commander-in-chief of the chilean army
that
a few days before these people are
bumped off
a cable will go out saying don't do it
guys and nevertheless it goes ahead and
this is again standard ci operating
procedure these operations are done to
preserve the cover
and so the united states then can take a
moral position while eliminating someone
that they consider to be an obstacle to
what they want to accomplish so alan
it seems
kind of contradictory that the cia is
secret the people are secret and yet in
your documentary you have interviews
with all these high cia officials and
you were able to talk to so many people
why is this because the ciu they have a
kind of false openness you see a lot of
what they do for instance in overseas
folks is they talk to the press they
manipulate the press i would say that if
you
took a percentage of their operations
you would find that a great
percentage-wise really have to deal
with getting out their line
through the media
because if they accomplish that
in a sense they control the way you see
a situation
they control the way you think about a
situation so they have an ability really
and they feel very much at ease with
press and media and they have
god knows the number of books which have
been written by former ci people take a
pro ci position and it's only recently
that there are some people like john
stock or philip agee and a couple of
other people who have really
decided well if the pro ci people are
writing books why don't we write books
but we'll really go into
the nature of some of these operations
so a lot of these people who are cia
operatives that you interviewed thought
they were using you and manipulating you
to get their point of view across wasn't
there a point that they found out that
this guy frank of rick may be doing a
hatchet job on us and at that time did
you get any less cooperation from the
cia or worse did you i don't think they
really paid much attention to what i was
doing you see because it was
i think at the moment when they realized
that this film was on a scale that they
had not even imagined because
you see you're dealing with five years
of your life you're dealing with a
research effort where i researched for
film background film and just about
every film library in the world
i
get a range of interviews of 50 to 60 to
80 people
and
on the other hand you have to realize
that for instance one of the persons
interviewed in the film is a former
president of cbs news the founding
president of cbs news and public affairs
and he says
that when he became president of cbs
news they had a relationship with the
cia
he had inherited this relationship and
it involved providing cover to ci
representatives but it also involved and
this is incredible providing any
material they have in their news library
to the ci friends of the cia i wanted to
identify somebody in a country who was
leading a demonstration
so you're dealing with a level of
collusion and you're dealing with the
fact that there's a level of contact at
the top level
of the networks and they're reaching 50
million people a night
so what the cia is concerned about
they're not concerned about a little
book or little newspaper article in the
nation
they're concerned about things which
really
tell you the truth about what they're
doing and in this case in ci on company
business it's entirely told you by
people in the agency and then reaching a
large number of people
because the very reason they keep their
operations secret
is because what they tried to explain
them to us
they would find very little to justify
them and since this country is still a
democracy we're still allowed to vote
and god knows how long that's going to
continue
it's going to be
they have to do this in the secret in
other words they're keeping them not so
much from the other countries because
i'm sure for instance in the case of
chile that the government of chile knew
the cia was trying to destroy their
government they're trying to keep them
from us
and that's why they are very upset with
some of the people who wrote books which
were much more forthcoming than they
would like to be and that's why this
film
because it has reached a
very large audience
is of concern to them now but when it
was being made i don't think they really
cared
one way or another at what point did the
cia begin harassing you if they did and
if so how did they do it did they try to
block the distribution in any way did
they try to defame you particularly
since the people who wrote books have
been taken to court
well you see the difference is that i
never worked for the ci phillip agent
john stackwell did work with the ci and
therefore they have a contractual
obligation with the cia
the second thing is that everything in
that film is so thoroughly documented in
other words that i said everybody tells
you what they did and
for instance william colby
talks about the program they had in
chile and tells you that it was a
program that started in the 60s where
they channeled a massive
sum of money into political parties
which would be just like the korean ci
deciding that they wanted to fund the
republican party with 20 million dollars
if they're doing exactly the same thing
in in
so
it's it's the structure of the film
which is the problem because as i said
you go through 35 years of history you
see all kinds of things
which people did not know
so the way they have dealt with the film
is the the film was actually shown on
the public broadcasting system
in 1980
and that was because there were people
in the broadcasting system who saw that
this film was going to be an historic
document it was going to be
it was going to go down as one of the
most important documentaries made you
know in the last so many years
what they did not realize was the kind
of political pressure they were going to
get and so therefore the response it was
supposed to be shown three times it was
shown once and they got enormous
pressure and it was yanked
um that's the first thing the second
thing is rather than deal with any of
the facts and challenge any of the facts
they have concocted an international
campaign
which is one of the standard things they
use accusing me of being an
international terrorist and i'm the kind
of person who doesn't even know how to
load a 38 caliber pistol
and what they did there was they took
for instance
certain
i'll give you an example when i was a
student at the university of california
myself and
my girlfriend and now my wife and some
other people we organized a film
society on campus
and the purpose of this was to show
films raise money
buy equipment so that students would be
able to make films and we called it the
film liberation front
so in other words
in this speech and some other planet
articles
a speech that congressman larry
macdonald made
from georgia
he goes on my background and he brings
up alan frankovich notorious founder of
the film liberation front
head berkeley and you know
and what he doesn't say is that i was a
fellow
of the american film institute in 1969
kind of the next year fellow at the
american federation of arts and then
so there's this campaign trying to link
us through the through the
very conservative extreme right-wing
press accuracy and media conservative
digest
because they're trying to ignore giving
us any attention getting into a
controversy like the controversy they
got into was missing
but then there's another level is that
in some countries
and the one
very specific example
is australia in australia the film was a
smash hit at the sydney film festival
then ran 14 to 16 weeks at a big theater
in sydney and then in the other cities
and so when i was there i was invited to
show the film to the
leadership of the australian labor party
which is like the british labour party
or the democratic party here and more or
less that tendency
the american ambassador found out about
this called up the national secretary of
the labor party and threatened them
but again didn't argue that there was
anything in the film that was inaccurate
to threaten them
that if they came to power again the
united states government would be in the
position of having to reconsider
relations with this uh and this is a
it's incredible this is a sovereign
country a political party in a foreign
country
which has every right
to see anything they want to
particularly a film which had already
been shown on public broadcasting here
and it's only a film it's not that
i'm quite willing to get into an open
debate on any form they want with anyone
where we can talk about these things as
a matter of fact that's what the film
was made to accomplish because
i don't see cbs doing it and you can
understand why
if the moment they started bringing it
out they would be in the position of
having to acknowledge their own
involvement
and you see the ci likes to do that they
like to get you involved and then they
will blackmail you what has been the
reception in the united states now when
it played here
for benefit for john stockwell over at
the law school auditorium the place was
packed the right wing could have wiped
out all the progressive people in austin
with one well-placed bomb they were all
there that night well it's been the
reviews have been
very very good
and
where it's played it's got very large
audiences and but we're having to put in
the effort
to actually get it released again
because there are obstacles and some of
the obstacles are commercial obstacles
have to do with the nature of the
of who owns theaters in this country and
the fact that documentaries uh
you have to prove that a documentary
will have an audience before that it
will be booked
and some of them have to have to do with
their attempt really to keep us from
from reaching this audience and
you have to realize that they're uh they
have contacts with a lot of people in
the media in this country
and i'm not saying that
necessarily a lot of people have been
bought by them but they have the
capacity to blackmail them and they also
they can make a journalist's reputation
simply by leaking to him the right kind
of information at the right time that's
an enormous power and if you're an
ambitious journalist
you take that into consideration
they have all kinds of ways of
corrupting the whole process of a
pre-press well also a lot of the theater
chains around the country are controlled
by big multinational corporations
that can make a political decision not
to release
certain films in fact i heard that reds
was being circulated through texas in a
cut version where some group in dallas
was marketing in this region they cut
out a lot of scenes
on the grounds that the theater owners
wanted a shorter movie but you see it's
difficult to say because sometimes that
is true because you just realize that
theater owners one thing motivates them
money
and for instance if they could show
uncommon business and make themselves
rich they'd do it i i i believe it they
would or film like missing you know
what happened there was the state
department attacked the film and it
simply doubled the audiences so in a
sense
they've been using uh these sort of
crank right wing crank newspapers to
attack the film or these accusations
that i'm an international terrorist
uh because they realized that if they
started
giving press conferences attacking the
film first of all they could not sustain
their argument
because as i said this film is entirely
told you by people in the cia and they
have never found a single faction which
cannot be defended which is pretty
remarkable given the amount of
information that's on that film and it's
a very dense informative film they
haven't been able to challenge anything
no they try to challenge the one thing
they try to challenge actually
is this that the ci had funded money
into the
labor unions and the trucks the trucker
strike in chile and they they try to
challenge that on the basis that seymour
hirsch who broke the story initially had
retracted
this but i you see i have to know why
seymour retracted it and it had to do
with a deal he made with somebody but
what they don't know is that i have an
interview with a chilean labor attache
the man who actually organized the
trucker strike which is not in the film
and he can confirm that and so you know
i'm not a pool i have
everything backed up i have everything
backed up and
i'd like to get into an argument with
them what about overseas have you been
able to market it overseas and what's
the reception been there well overseas
it's been in 35 countries it's been for
instance uh
i just was in mexico where the former
president of mexico i sat with him for
three hours he saw the film
uh what was his reaction
his reaction was shock
he was who was the louis
according to phil agee in his book on
inside the company he was the contact in
mexico city
before he became president with aj he
was the ceo well you see you you have a
situation where anybody who was a
minister of interior in any latin
american country would have some contact
with the cia
but one thing you have to realize about
the ci is the cia has different ways of
using people
in other words
you can be convinced that uh the united
states policy is fine and you want to
allow yourself with the united states
and not even be aware of the other
levels of manipulation that they're
doing with you
and they have a way of dragging you in a
step at a time in terms of its ideas
association i know nothing
about
i do know that when you see the full
scope of this and the devious nature of
the way they operate and how everything
is
done in such a way that you
might be part of this operation and you
won't
deliberately won't be given the rest of
the parts the levels of manipulation are
absolutely incredible
um
because
you you manipulate your agents which are
the locals in that country
and then if you're a ci officer working
out of diplomatic cover or on a
business cover
you in turn can be manipulated and you
will be sacrificed
you are expected if you get caught
to be sacrificed you will just be left
behind and you're supposed to take the
blame
that's one of the reasons john stockwell
got turned off on the cia he became
personally attached to some of the
people he worked with in some of his
operations and didn't like to see them
get beat up or murdered or whatever
once
he left and the operation had collapsed
well there's one of the one one of the
people interviewed in the film joseph
brookholder smith he describes the
nature of your relationship with an
agent as just it's like being a con man
working on the mark in other words
working on your target the only person
who doesn't know what the game is is
your target and you simply are
you lure them in with whatever it is it
can be blackmail sex money it can be on
ideology
but you have a plan for him
or her that they're not aware of and you
simply uh
and so there's a dishonesty at the very
basis of the relationship what about
other countries besides mexico you said
35 to 38 countries it's been released
or will be released in just about every
european country where it's been on
television
and
a lot of latin american countries and
some african countries
in australia new zealand it's been at 15
to 18 film festivals and won some prizes
right
at the two prizes at the two festivals
competing at one of the top prize it
could not compete in con because it had
been at the berlin festival
well what about the new information
about the cia that's come out recently
you have any taps to what's going on any
books that are coming out for instance
well there i know of a couple of books
coming out including as a new book
coming out by someone who worked in
vietnam and thailand
his name is ralph mcgee which should be
coming out in the next few months but i
think you could you can see if you see
on company business and the kind of
methods the ci
has used over the past you can see their
hand
in a lot of different parts of the world
for instance i don't know uh
president carter just admitted
i think in the last week's newsweek or
time
that during the hostage crisis uh the
united states was using media cover to
get its uh agents into iran and of
course the iranian government at that
time was saying that and no one none of
the media were covering it
and uh they kicked all the media out at
one point on the ground and people
thought they were just being paranoid
yes but here's carter admitting that
they were justified from their point of
view right and and you're in the kind of
situation
where you find all of these
things are happening and you know some
country accuse the united states of
doing something and the american media
just ignores it or ridicules it and then
five years later you find out that in
fact that they've done all that
more in fact there was just a
document that was leaked to the
washington post last week which was a
what 60-some page
document
put together by the house of
representatives not exactly a radical
group
listing all of the cia operations in
central america over the last few years
and being quite critical of some of them
did you get any information on that have
you seen the booklet yet or no i haven't
seen the booklet yet but you can see for
instance
in central america it has to be one of
the arenas where they're extremely
active well they've admitted that
they're channeling 19 million dollars
into
corporate programs against nicaraguan
isn't that something new where they're
actually coming out and saying okay
we're doing this that is new and it
isn't no you see because you know what
it really is it's like telling somebody
look i have this big club here and
either you do and i'm telling you i've
got this club and either you do what i
want or i'm going to hit you over the
head
and it's meant to intimidate it's meant
to frighten it's meant to to
people moderate
representation so it's not because you
have to realize that for instance during
the sea ice program against cuba
i have for instance i must have five
hours
of material which was filmed by the
american media
including i have material which shows in
1961 frank sturgis
training
cuban liberation fighters in the
everglades
which obviously he he was working for
the ci then right he uh
the ci station in miami arranged for
them
uh to film he was one of the people in
watergate yes one of the watergate
and so possibly the kennedy kennedy says
he pops up everywhere right
but you but you're in the kind of
situation where you have the same thing
happening now in honduras and you have
the same and you have photographs being
taken of people training in miami and in
california and it's just like miami in
the early 60s and if you actually sit
down and watch this footage and look at
the statements i mean you can see them
circulating the same press releases
almost except changing the country from
cuba to nicaragua you mentioned cuba i
can't recall how much you went into this
in your film was this a major topic and
wasn't there also a book recently that
came out by warren henkel who's a friend
of yours that documents the us
operations against cuba what's the name
of that book it's the name of it is the
fish the fish is red which was the code
word
which they used to inform
their underground in cuba that the bay
of pigs invasion was going to occur that
day or week
well the film goes into
into the cuban operation in some detail
because it's the first
example of a major paramilitary
operation which involved assassinations
it involved destroying the economy and
involved and
this is told you by richard helms
involved blowing up bridges and involved
as a matter of fact richard helms
in the film says well why should i have
told the congress about our attempts to
assassinate fidel castro when we were
essentially killing thousands of cuban
citizens
and this program that went on in years
and and
fever you know well
well really with bullets not even
getting into the exotic things they were
blowing up bridges they were burning
down sugar they were bombing they were
uh they were terrorist attacks
they were sponsoring and what's
interesting
is through all of this you know if you
talk to americans they think my cuban is
such a threat there has not been and the
ci has never accused the cubans of
killing a single american citizen
in the united states they have never
accused the cubans of blowing up a
single american bridge a single american
industrial plan and yet they feel
perfectly justified to have done this
over
a period of time ships oil refineries
they've broken up their sugar cane etc
chemical warfare bacteriological warfare
in fact now that i think of it uh bill
moyers made a cbs reports called the
cia's
war or secret army that really
documented the u.s involvement in cuba
were there things that he left out there
that you thought about what he left out
was
you know everyone was surprised to see
these people give interviews so freely
but they had the habit of doing it i
mean the ci stations miami for years had
been arranging for them to be
interviewed because they wanted to agree
with the impression that this was a huge
movement uh there were all of these
cubans who were just raring to go in and
liberate their their homeland from
tyranny etc and so a lot of what ci does
is it's public relations of that sort
it's really creating uh
the appearance of of
this huge movement
and
everyone was surprised because you see
i i have a lot of the stories which go
back to
60 61 62 that whole period every time uh
the cuban kind of revolutionary groups
uh the ci groups like alpha 66 had a
convention
there they filmed it and there were
interviews and before the bay of pigs i
have footage of cuban nationals
going around giving press conferences
and asking for recruits now in this in
the united states according to the
federal
code that is a criminal offense you
cannot amount it's it's something they
can put you in jail for for five years
you can't recruit aren't foreign armies
exactly
in the country
well how alan would you characterize the
cia under reagan
are there new
sorts of operations is it unleashed on a
wider scale or is it more or less doing
what it had been doing
for decades well it's doing what it's
been doing for decades but in a
different context in the sense that
internationally more people are aware of
their methods and i think americans
generally understand some americans
understand
but but the ci now has
the right to do things inside this
country that it never legally could do
before in other words uh and i'll
predict
that in the on
using the justification of fighting
terrorism and in some instances
they are going to be encouraging
and publicizing terrorist incidents in
order to
get everyone nervous
you're going to see them
start
doing things inside this country
to control people
that
they've been preparing to do for some
period of time in other words
well they have the right now for
instance to infiltrate
any kind of political organization any
kind of uh
group at all
uh in this country which is what they
were not allowed to do before partly
because of the of the contradictions and
the uh
the problems of jurisdiction between the
fbi and the cia
[Music]
and that is really
uh they can do it on the flimsy flimsies
of excuses and if somebody who is a
member of one of these organizations
says hey i think that guy's a cia they
can put him in jail for five years
exactly
exactly because they've just passed a
law making it a felony to name the name
of ci people
and that's not going to stop for
instance foreign newspapers from naming
the names of ci people it is going to
make it very difficult and intimidating
for any american press and as i said the
reason the ci exists
is not to keep these covert operations
secret from the countries that are being
targeted the nicaraguans
or having their own people killed every
week
know the ci is behind these things
we don't though we read the things and
say oh it's just another one of those
accusations these operations are secret
to keep them from us
and to preclude our deciding what we
want our foreign policy to be
and so it becomes who you vote for
anymore because the president is still
going to go on using the secret
instrument and that's why i think the
issue of covert operates into the ci is
critical
well alan it's not just the names of
agents which can't be
talked about anymore it's any of the
activities of the of any of the
intelligence services and that includes
the fbi or the bureau of alcohol tax and
firearms that means that you wouldn't
able be able to make your documentary on
company business now right right it
would be extremely difficult to make and
uh
but it also means that for instance if
and there are documented incidents if
you have someone in your
group
who proposes to you
a terrorist incident and is actually
working for the fbi or the ci and this
has happened in the past that you are
not even allowed to name
to denounce him at a press comments that
so and so has suggested we blow up an
oil refinery etc and that we know that
this man is working for the cia they can
actually throw you in jail for five
years
for revealing that in other words so you
have no form at all of protection and
it's like uh
creating the legal basis for the
creation of an enormously powerful
secret police force
um inside for use in this country
and that's exactly why you know i think
watergate the watergate investigation
occurred because as i said one in this
case richard nixon made a big mistake
and that was to use the cia
elements connected with the ci inside
this country against the other major
party against the other major party and
the other major party was not about to
just roll over and die
well there are some people who say that
it was the cia who was very instrumental
in breaking down richard nixon
about the tapes for instance yeah but
you have to understand that there are
people who understand that the
destruction of the ci would be it's when
it gets politicized now it becomes an
instrument where
whatever party is in power appoints a
political appointee so they can protect
themselves from destabilization efforts
then it's going to it's going to
ruin it as an agency because you see an
intelligence agency and there are
american presidents and even ci
directors who are concerned about
accurate information
i'll give you an example which is a very
dramatic one one of the people
interviewed in the film is jesse leaf
who is the former ci chief analyst on
iran
his job among other things was to take
all the intelligence they had from every
source in other words from their
satellite surveillance from their
telephone tabs and telecommunications
surveillance
from their agents uh from in the army
the secret police whatever
and
project
first of all describe what was happening
in iran in every sector of the society
and then project what the trends would
be over a certain period of time
and these reports are prepared and
everything is documented it's like doing
a
thesis
you refer to where you get all the
information he concluded in 1971 or 72
that the whole thing was going to blow
up
that the level of corruption was
extraordinary the shah was antagonizing
everybody everybody was going to unite
against him
he prepared this report and this is on
the basis of his honest appraisal
submitted it to the agency
the head of the iran desk the next day
called him and said this is unacceptable
he asked why it was unacceptable he was
told it's unacceptable because it's just
unacceptable well what he discovered was
that this man
who had
had on the uh worked as a consultant to
the shah
uh
number one number two there were major
american economic interests that were at
stake and and they didn't care what
happened in iran as long as they made
300 million dollars a year profits
if they could get five more years like
that the whole thing could go to hell at
the end of the period of time and they
wouldn't give a damn
so that's what he was fighting about
this was a single individual you know
this is like this is like an american
movie it's like a gary cooper movie this
lone guy
not a gunslinger walking down the street
representing honesty etc and he runs up
against the whole structure which is
saying no no we don't care what happens
and in the film he tells you
that he knew
that the savak was torturing people his
boss
went to iran and spent five years
organizing the savak he had all kinds of
reports about this
um
that the ci was running iran
that the chav iran was a ci agent and
this man is the emperor of emperors the
emperor the persian king of kings
tracing himself back to darius and
xerxes and yet the ci chief of station
would call him up and he would volunteer
information on what was happening in the
royal palace
and so what they see is they see the
embassy taken over
and americans say my god these people
are ungrateful we've been channeling all
this money and they don't even know that
rather than channeling all this money
they have been leading the country
right they've been running the country
everyone in iran knows it you have
and so the anger comes out of that
and you look at the american media
coverage of iran and compare with
european media coverage that's
incredible um i know of cases for
instance where the
iranians made available savak agents
to the press they could interview them
who were trained in the united states of
the international police academy
i even know the case of one man when he
was trained here invented a torture
instrument which is a pretty frightening
thing because what it is it's like a
hair dryer those all women's hair dryers
and what they would do is they would put
it over your head over your ears and
they would torture you in your own
screams it was designed so it was
acoustically such that your own screams
would actually
reverberate in your ears
and of course you might say well this
man might have been planted the iranians
are making propaganda but at least
someone should have gone and talked to
them and checked it out and checked it
out nobody did listen they're a similar
story with vietnam that has become a
national
scandal recently where there was a cia
analyst an intelligence analyst in
vietnam who was supposed to assess the
troop strength of the viet cong and the
north vietnamese troops and would send
reports in that were according to a cbs
news report discounted by westmoreland
and the military establishment did you
do you have any position on that issue
which is now i guess westmoreland sued
cbs claiming that they defamed him tv
guide has had giant articles about it
etc do you have any
insight into this issue well i i know a
whole series of other people were in
vietnam who who ran into the same
problem in terms of that specific issue
it's clear to me that what happened
there whether westmoreland westmoreland
is suing them on the basis of whether he
knew or didn't know
is that they really didn't want uh
the facts to come out that they were not
winning the war in vietnam just like
they don't want the facts to come out
that the government they're supporting
an el salvador is losing the war because
the whole
basis of this is is to is to rather than
do you know what the american president
should do when this country's in a
crisis is to get on television and say
this is what we have to do there
we have just discovered that the soviet
union is going to invade el salvador and
we have to do this and the other thing
no what they do is because they know
that's not true
and in terms of vietnam
for instance one of the persons i
interviewed in the film
and this is interesting in
if you just remember the recent el
salvador election results
uh his name is paul sackler he was the
chief
of the iran of the vietnam desk when
kobe made his first tour
in vietnam and he was reading to me
cables
of how the vietnamese intelligence
service was a completely owned
adjunct of the cia then and to the end
they were rigging the elections he had
these cables coming in you know we're
coming in there report tremendous people
and so i mean there you have this is
diem
the ci later arranges to eliminate
and here you have you know a government
which invites the united states in which
the united states first of all brings to
power and so when it's like inviting
yourself in you know it's like having
yourself
manipulating the elections i mean
they're playing the election so that you
can bring in someone who will invite you
in and make sure that someone who wants
to kick you out
so it wouldn't surprise me at all in
terms of the sam adams story
but
the problem is how do you get accurate
intelligence and if you're discouraging
anyone who who is trying to be honest
and report information
which he believes an american president
uh should know
in order precisely to preclude what
happened in iran was you know finally i
mean the relationship that the united
states
this is an important point that the cia
is not really an intelligence
agency they're not providing accurate
intelligence which they're supposed to
do by their charter rather they're an
arm of covert action
and isn't there something like six major
issues where the cia had either
inaccurate information or if they did in
the case of iran and some vietnam
reports they were at one place in the
bureaucracy kept from the political
decision people
so that they've really been a a major
failure as an intelligence agent because
intelligence really is not what concerns
if you're dealing you know at the top
level you're dealing with economic
interests
you're dealing with
why should the president of the united
states listen to some little flunky ci
analyst who says look this thing in iran
is going to blow up in our faces
people are just going to get mad at us
they're going to kick us out
this whole thing is going to go to hell
when
at the same time somebody's calling up
and saying look you know
the shah's our friend
and none of that but we have
major dealings you know we're getting
300 million dollars by selling them
helicopters and you see you have the
irony that the
iran is fighting the war with iraq now
with arms of the shah bought
and the united states
have every reason to believe that
they're encouraging the iraqis but
because you know they see the iranian
process is
very dangerous
because it's a nationalist process and
if it spreads over
into saudi arabia and the saudis
realize that
that the kings of saudi arabia have sold
them down the river and will keep on
selling them down the river forever
that will have an impact but the um
so
the the and you know one of the most
interesting examples in the interesting
book
it just came out about the ci
intervention in guatemala uh on the base
of the documents released and it's clear
that in 1953 or 54 when the ci got
involved in guatemala it had nothing at
all to do with this communist threat as
a matter of fact
the cia arranged to plant themselves
russian weapons in nicaragua and arrange
the masa
discovery of them so that they could
justify the communist threat this comes
out these are actual ci documents which
state this
now let's say there is
there was a soviet threat to guatemala
and if the cia is any kind of
intelligence organization that should be
able to say and give to the president
this information
and the president should be able to say
we are now invading guatemala
because there are
and if you go down every instance you go
down to guatemala you go down to santo
domingo the famous lbj thing in santa
flamingo where he came up with 35 known
communists
and these people were enough of a threat
to send in thirty thousand marines this
is a dominican republic in 1965
you go down every instance like that
there always is the first thing the
other side is going to do this
or you know in the case of chile you
have the famous remark that henry
kissinger made which was then publicized
after the indiana government was
overthrown that chile is like the only
threat chile is it's a dagger pointed to
the heart of antarctica
and nevertheless they go down they
destroy the government they kill the
president and they feel perfectly proper
to do this they feel no problem at all
they feel
you uh mentioned some people analysts
and all who
apparently try to
develop some information
relative to the truth in the cia
has there been any dissonance in the cia
itself has been any struggles from below
and discussed with what the cia is doing
other than the people who get out and
write books
yes well you see what's interesting is
that you take the america the washington
press
there are all kinds of reasons stories
appear and often stories are leaked by
somebody in the ci or another
intelligence agency wants to get even
with their boss they want to eliminate
their boss you have to realize that
these things are bureaucracy just like
an insurance company and people have all
kinds of reasons for telling
and for instance jesse leaf who entered
the cia he told me the story
he entered the ci he had come in with a
younger generation of people who had
actually been at american universities
and the best american universities
during the anti-war days
and so uh when he entered uh
his generation of ci people had a
different attitude like they insisted on
child care for their children
uh in 1970 actually
there was a furore in the ci when the
united states and nixon sent the troops
into cambodia and they had sit down
strikes they had petitions
and uh and the cia itself cia employees
i never heard that jesse leaf told me
and uh and they're in the kind of
situation where you see it's very
difficult work
in the sense that the kind of people
that the ci looks for are motivated
they're intelligent
um
they're aggressive
and you have to believe in what you're
doing
and many of the people who later became
the ci's biggest critics like
philippegee he joined the cia
had gone to catholic school all his life
believed when he joined the cia he was
defending god democracy family anything
you can think of someone like john
stockwell said the same thing
and when you start realizing that you're
defending none of those things as a
matter of fact you're destroying those
things
and i'm not even talking in terms of the
immorality of the operations but you
the ci is creating the conditions
for everyone in the rest of the world to
hate this country
because they're not paying attention to
what our american presidents are saying
we're the ones who have to listen to
ronald reagan
thank god
they're paying attention to what this
country is doing to help them
the people in el salvador are not paying
attention to what ronald reagan is
saying
he's trying to bring democracy they know
who's bombing them and they know where
the bombs are coming from and they know
where the shells are coming from and
they know who's training the troops and
they're seeing what those troops are
doing
and there's no way you're ever going to
convince you might convince a student
that this is right or this is wrong on
the basis of
abstractions but when you're a peasant
and you've just seen your neighbor's
family taken out and all shot down with
american bullets there's no possible way
that they're going to buy a ronald
reagan speech next time around
alan do you have any insight into what
kind of a person is in the cia today we
talked about the earlier generation of
people that thought they were doing good
fighting for democracy freedom etc
against communism we've seen the
disillusion of that generation we've
read their books people like john
stockwell philip agee what kind of
person is in the cia today after all of
these revelations
of the evil that they've done all over
the world is it sort of a cynical
careerist opportunity
but i think they're trying to recreate
you see the consensus
and one of the reasons we're having
investigations was to great yeah that
was in the past we were doing those
things we're not doing them anymore
because i said um
and you know a lot of people under think
they're under pressure to get a job and
so the ci has been very active on
campuses recruiting
and um uh
but the problem you say
they're having as i said much of the
world i think if you mentioned 20 years
ago
the word sea i knew that nobody even
knew what it meant if you mentioned it
today uh people might not have a very
clear sense of what it is or uh
but they do know that the ci had
something to do with perhaps the
assassinating people that was involved
in the coup in chile
the things they might not know is this
extensive operation of the trade union
movement it's extensive penetration of
the american media its use of religious
groups even
and its continuing use of religious
groups
but i think the kind of people are
looking for the same kinds of people
they have to be people who believe in
what they're doing who are motivated but
i think in this
case people are
some people are probably saying to
themselves well
uh
it's a job like any other job because a
lot of it is pushing around paper and
analyzing you know ci has a lot of
intellectual people who do analyses
of societies
same thing you would do if you were a
professor and don't see any problem
because they don't have to
face what's at the end of the line
because the cio is the kind of
organization that will to accomplish
many of its most vicious ends it will be
the command and control it will hire
local people because they're poor you
can buy them
very cheaply and the actual trigger
pulling will be done
that might be the one difference between
the ci and say other cigarette police
forces is the americans have an american
way of doing that and they don't like
to pull out the fingernails you know in
other words somebody else just finds
somebody else to do it and so you don't
have to face the moral consequences
yeah that seems to go ahead yet someone
that's working for this agency and
seeing all these revelations of all the
dirty tricks and evil deeds done by the
cia must know
that this agency is doing all of these
things and how can one rationalize
this or is it just suppressed well what
they do you see those this is where for
instance they are trying to do
everything they can to destroy the
reputations of people like john
stockwell and philip agee
because those people
uh
create
such a bad example
so therefore philip he they have accused
him over and over again of working for
the cubans are working for the soviets
uh
john stockwell the same kinds of things
i mean the senator from utah
hatched uh
essentially got into a
discussion with him at a senate hearing
on
because they don't want
americans to realize is that they have
nothing to do with american patriotism i
mean i can say that the people who are
running the ci now
if they had been in the american
revolution they would have been running
the british
army
how so i didn't get that
because
they are on the side
of manipulation they don't believe in
democracy anywhere certainly not here
and nowhere they're they're not
interested in
in defending anyone's real security they
they're an instrument which defends
certain very powerful economic interests
which are just as willing to uh to see
american workers fired they're not going
to be making uh money as they would need
to see guatemalan workers killed
and that's the reality of it and they've
wrapped themselves up in the flag too
long you take a person like john mccone
director of the central intelligence
agency
on the board of directors of
international telephone and telegraph
one of the founders of bechtel
corporation
you look at his life
over the last he has not given a single
drop of blood ever to this country and
he certainly made himself enormously
rich
and you contrast that with the life of
many other people gone through and he
you know
appears in the film and justifies what
they did in chile because international
telephone and telegraph was worried that
their telephone company was going to get
nationalized in chile
and the chilean government did
nationalize it and compensated them for
their book investment in other words
their declared investment
30 million dollars whatever is which
they declare as the worth they didn't
feel that was justified because of
course they were under declaring what
the real wealth was so they wouldn't
have to pay taxes so they kind of got
hoisted by their own little tax evasion
scheme
it looks like the cia then is the
massive hit squad of the multinational
corporate system
yeah i think that's that's why the film
is called on comedy business you know
attention at the ci the people in the ci
refer to themselves as the company
and if you look at
strictly you look at say the world
situation the geopolitical situation the
united states has two
and now
actually four major rivals i'd used to
just be the two major communist
countries the soviet union and and china
the ci has had never had any success at
all against those two countries
in the 50s they were parachuting people
into russia
to set up gorillas and they all got
wiped out the most china the same thing
uh
they've been extremely successful
against guatemala
against iran against chile against
angola
against any of a number of countries
although some of those backfired like
the angola well a lot of them are going
to backfire in the end you see because
it's because
it comes down do you really think
in the end that you can control
people by beating them down by getting
them mad at you by making them starve to
death and watch their children die at
four or five years old
and in the end i don't think you can
because in the end if you're gonna watch
your children die at four or five years
old you're going to come out and fight
that's all you have that's all you have
left
um
and so uh
and one of the great stories i like to
tell is how james angleton the head of
the ci's counterintelligence corps
and this is the part of the ci which is
designed to protect the ci from
penetration by soviet agents
well the highest level soviet
penetration we know of into western
intelligence at least that i know of is
kim philby
who was a top british intelligence
officer who was working for the soviet
union for the last 20 or 30 years
he was stationed in washington
to be the liaison between the ci and the
british intelligence service
particularly on soviet
affairs and kim philly at one point was
in charge of these parachute drops into
the soviet union and of course these
people never survived
when he was in in washington james
angleton who loves the british has a
great anglophile
uh he went to yav university and thinks
came to an oxford he would have lunch
with philby about three times a week and
god knows what they discussed i'm not
saying that angleton is working for the
soviet union but he certainly couldn't
see what was right in front of his face
because this man was talking with a
british accent was brow beating him with
a british accent and and so on
so here you have this great organization
with 10
000 employees and god knows what their
budget is because that's a secret
going up and beating up you know
people in guatemala which is no big
accomplishment really
putting the poverty there you mentioned
a couple minutes ago that america had
four major enemies the soviet union and
red china that they'd had well no luck
against uh those two what are the other
two japan now in other words because you
realize united stand economic rival yeah
but you see when the way they look have
to look at that level it's it's rivals
if japan is outselling you know if
americans are buying toyotas here rather
than chevrolet's
they're becoming a rival and sony rather
than rca exactly
as a final question can you tell us
during the process of making the film
before and afterward
how it changed you if at all
well it changed me in a sense that i
knew something about cia operations what
i didn't understand is the utter
ruthlessness
and and the banality of it in other
words that it happens day in and day out
and
that it uh
that the people that are involved in
this whole process are just it's like
talking to a bunch of insurance
executives
they look at themselves as technologists
in other words they just have this is a
technique for destabilization and
destroy they never come to the
the moral consequences never have to
face the moral consequences and you're
dealing with a very
a kind of rotary club version of a
gestapo
uh because they're smiling they're
affable they're open
i could say that i got along very well
with everybody i interviewed in the film
but nevertheless if you look at what
happens at the end of the process and i
had occasion to see that because my
father was a mining engineer and so i
grew up
in latin american countries
and i had a very early awareness of the
relationship
and say
between the united states and some of
these other countries we were supporting
every half-assed dictator military
hunter
oligarchy that existed
in the third world
as long as they promised to somehow
maintain the status quo
which would of course be beneficial to
u.s
geopolitical interests
military interests big business
interests and other special interests
have government agencies like the
congress the senate committee for
example oversight of to oversee the cia
talking about the agency now being under
control and that the abuses of the past
have now been eliminated as if the
agency wasn't under control all along
and as if what they call abuses weren't
ordered by presidents
the main argument is not with the agency
which is an instrument for policy
execution but the main argument is with
the president and the people outside the
cia who determine the interests which
have to be protected and how
who determine american foreign policy
and then call upon the cia and other
agencies to execute that policy
the system is what is wrong the system
is what has
to be changed and should be changed
and that's our program for tonight watch
alternative views each week for news and
information you won't get anywhere else
on television
alternative views is a production of the
alternative information network
a non-profit tax-free corporation
we'd love to hear it from you if you'd
like to write us
please write to po box
7279
austin texas
78712
good night